حياكم الله الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد
ترامب يتهم اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
بملاحقته وتشويه سمعته والتحقيق معه حتى
يضمن الحزب الديمقراطي من الفوز في
الانتخابات القادمه تصريحات ترامب جاءت
بما وصف انه اكبر تجمع انتخابي دعا اليه
الملياردير الامريكي انصاره بمدينه واقف
في ولايه تكساس هناك تابع اتهامه بان
استغلال اداره بايدن لاجهزه انفاذ القانون
في امريكا يرقى لما قام به ستالين في
الاتحاد السوفيتي وفق روترز مضيفا ان
الولايات المتحده اضحت مثل جمهوريات الموز
بسبب تزوير الانتخابات وفق قوله مشيرا الى
ان اداره بايدن تنشغل بملاحقته ولم تعد
تهتم بالصين التي تهدد المصالح الامريكيه
وفق قوله واعتبر ترامب انه ورغم ما تبذله
اداره بايدل لسحقه وانصاره الا انهم جعلوا
منهم اقوياء وصفه متواعدا بقرب انتهاء
ولايه الديمقراطيين وعوده الحريه لامريكا
على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
استخدام السلطه موجود في كافه مستويات
الحكومه هناك فساد مستشرم في كل مكان هذا
يحدث امام اعيننا لكننا سنفوز ان استخدام
نظام بايدن لاجهزته في انفاذ القانون يرقى
لما قام به ستالين في السابق ويبدو ان هذا
بدا منذ بدايه الشيوعيه ونحن نبدو وكاننا
جمهوريه من جمهوريات العالم الثالث
جمهوريه الموز مع تزوير الانتخابات اضحينا
جمهوريه الموز ان العداله يجب ان تتحقق
نحن سوف ندافع عن ذلك عندما تنتهي تلك
الانتخابات وساكون رئيسا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اورلاندو عبر توم حرب رئيسه
تحالف الامريكيه الشرق اوسطيه للديمقراطيه
ومن واشنطن الدكتور عدنان غريبه الاستاذ
في العلاقات الدوليه لابدا اولا من واشنطن
دكتور ادموند يعني اليوم حينما نتحدث عن
هذا الظهور
لترامب بعد فتره وخاصه بعد هذه القضيه هل
هو ضحيه ام جاني وفق الاتهام
تحياتي لك وللاستاذ حرب من الواضح ان
الرئيس ترامب يواجه تحديات كبيره وضغوط من
القياده الديمقراطيه اما اذا كان مذنبا ام
لا فهذا يجب ان يترك وللمحكمه ولكن من
الواضح ان هناك ايضا عمليه تسييس من وراء
هذه التحركات فمنذ اليوم الاول لوصوله الى
البيت الابيض في 2016 كان هناك اتهامات
ومطالبات من قبل وسائل الاعلام بعض وسائل
الاعلام الرئيسيه مثلا صحيفه واشنطن بوست
في اليوم الاول لتنصيب الرئيس طالبت بعزله
واستمرت هذه كانت هناك اتهامات له بانه
تواطى مع الروس وان هذا ادى الى انتخابه
وان الروس تدخلوا في الحملات الانتخابيه
الامريكيه
وانه هو ايضا تلاعب
بضرائبه
وبالتالي فانه يحاكم
وبالتالي فان هناك الكثير من الاتهامات
التي وجهت لترامب ولكن هذه المساله هي
ربما الان هناك ثلاث قضايا
يعني موجهه ضد ترامب في واحده في نيويورك
واحده في واشنطن وواحده في الجو ولايه
جورجيا بعضها له علاقه بموقفهم من
الانتخابات والاتهامات بان الانتخابات
كانت مزوره والاخيره التي لها علاقه ايضا
بدوره في دفع اموال لمحامي لكي يدفع
ممثله اباحيه كل هذه الامور طبعا من ناحيه
هي طبعا موجهه ضد ترامب واذا تمت ادانته
هذه من ناحيه قد
تثير اسئله والكثير عندئذ سيعتمد على
نتائج المحاكمه ولكن في في نفس الوقت الذي
نرى ذلك نرى ايضا ان ترامب قد بدا هذه هي
النقطه الاهم انه في انظار
انصاره وله الكثير من الانصار في الولايات
المتحده وفي الحزب الجمهوري ينظر اليه على
الضحيه
للالاعيب السياسيه للحكومه الاتحاديه والى
اداره
الاداره الديمقراطيه سيتم حرب رئيسه
التحالف الامريكي الشرق اوسطيه
للديمقراطيه التحول في اول ظهور اعلاميه
للرئيس السابق هذا الظهور الاول في حمله
الانتخابيه غير انه استغله لدعايته تحوله
وغير التكتيك من موقع المدافع الى موقف
المهاجم كسب ام ربما
ازاح النظر عن هذه القضايا المرفوعه ضده
اهلا وسهلا
بالنسبه للسؤال بالزائد انا بتصور انه هو
عارف ماذا يفعل الرئيس ترامب والشعب
الامريكي يعرف الحقيقه باستثناء اليسار
الامريكي لا يجهل الحقيقه لانه الاعلام
اليس الولايات المتحده مسيس تجاه الحزب
الديمقراطي فلذلك الامر يعني هذه مشكله ان
كانت مشكله في ولايه فليست هي يجب ان لا
تخرج النظام الفيدرالي والانتخابات
الفيدراليه ولكن هي مسيسه في النيور
مدعومه
المدعي العامه مدعوم من جورج سوروس
المعروف اليساري المتميز
فمن هذه النظره الشعب الامريكاني يعرف
الحقيقه وبدا يعتبر الرئيس ترامب هو ضحيه
النظام
القضائين قضاء لليمين الامريكي
المتعصف وقضاء للحزب الديمقراطي
والديمقراطيين وهو خفيف على هؤلاء
المجموعات ولكن الرئيس ترامب
بالفعل اصبح مهاجم حسب ما رايناه نهار امس
للدفاع عن الولايات المتحده قال بان الحزب
الديمقراطي يستغل هذه المحاكمات الضعيفه
لابعاد النظر عن المشاكل الخارجيه وهنا ثم
الصين بشكل خاص لانه نحن نعرف الصين كيف
برزت على الساحه الدوليه ان كانت في الشرق
الاوسط اما في روسيا واوكرانيا وربما في
امريكا اللاتينيه الرئيس لولو سيذهب الى
زياره الصين الاسبوع القادم الرئيسه
الرئيس السابقه
ما يكون الرئيس السابق ترامب يتحدث بهذه
الطريقه وكان لديها العصا السحريه في حل
كل المشاكل الامريكيه في حال عودته الى
سده الحكم سيتم
راينا على المكان على اربع سنين راينا اذا
كان هنالك من اي حروب اما مشاكل ربما
انتهت وراينا بان الروس لم يستفزوا
اوكرانيا مثل ما استفزوها بعهد الرئيس
السابق اوباما واليوم دخلوا المعركه ضد
اوكرانيا راينا الصين بعهد الرئيس ترامب
كان هنالك حرب اقتصاديه وليست مثلم
الاستفزاز للتايوان على سبيل المثل حتى
هندورس هندورس هي بامريكا الوسطى فهي
بخاصره الولايات المتحده عمدا ان تكون
صديقه وتتبع سياسات الولايات المتحده كررت
اليوم الغاء
الدبلوماسيه مع تايوان
الرئيس الرئيس السابقه للبرازيل اصبحت
اليوم رئيسه البريكس اهون وهو البنك
المرادف للبنك الدولي يعني اليوم اذا
البنك الدولي مقاطع اي دوله اموال هنالك
الصين وروسيه
وجنوب افريقيا والبرا زيل بامكانهم ان
يعطوا يمولوا مشاريع دوليه عوضا عن بنك
الدول تتراجع السياسه الامريكيه في عهد
الرئيس
وهذا اختار ليس للديمقراط خسارها للشعب
الامريكي ككل طيب عوده الحريه لامريكا على
حد التعبير الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب
الدكتور ادموند اضافه الى عودته ايضا الى
النغمه القديمه بتزوير الانتخابات لكن هذه
المره اضاف عليها استغلال الرئيس الحالي
لسلطاته
وما ذلك لاقصائه عن الانتخابات الى اي مدى
قد يؤثر ذلك في الشارع حقيقه فعلا بدون
شكل موقف ترامب ضمن الحزب الجمهوري ضمن
القاعده الجمهوريه هو الان يبدو كانه اقوى
لان الكثيرين بداوا ينظروا الى ما يجري
على انه عمليه مسيسه هدفها ابعاده او
هرمانه من ترشيح نفسه او اضعافه او اذا
نجح في الاستمرار في الحمله ورشح نفسه
للانتخابات ولكن في نفس الوقت اعتقد ان
ترامب ايضا يلعب لعبه ذكيه الى حد ما فهو
يربط
مظالمه كما هو يراها بمظالم الشعب
الامريكي وهو وكما يقول للجمهور انهم لا
يلاحقونني انا بل انهم يلاحقونكم انتم
عندما تحدث كان يتحدث في خطابه في ولايه
في ويكو في ولايه ايضا اختياره لهذه
البلده ايضا كان مهما لانه
حدثت فيها مواجهه عنيفه بين مجموعه دينيه
صغيره
وهجمت من قبل القوى
الحكوميه وقتل عدد كبير من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال فيها ولذلك فهو يريد ان يقول بان
الدوله العميقه هي التي تهدد الولايات
المتحده وانه اذا فاز هو فهو الذي سيحرر
الامريكيين من نفوذ هذه الدوله العميقه
ولكن طبعا الكثير سيعتمد على ما سيجري
خلال هذه التحقيقات ولكنه هو ايضا استغل
هذه الفرصه
لتاطير الى حد كبير تاطير مظالمه بمظالم
الشعب الامريكي وهو وجه اتهاماته الى
المدعين العامين الذين قالوا بان لديهم
يستغلوا
يسيء استغلال
[موسيقى]
الدستوريه لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه طيب سيد
حرب يعني هذه الخطوه من انه قال باننا
نعيش جمهوريات الموز بسبب تزوير
الانتخابات وكما يحدث في الاتحاد السوفيتي
يعني هذه الرساله لمن تصل لانصاره امن
الطرف الاخر خاصه انه الشارع الامريكي
منقسم
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين للجمهوريين وحتى
هناك انقسام في الشارع الجمهوري او الحزب
الجمهوري من هو مؤيد ومن هو معارض لترامب
اول شيء نحن
الحزب الجمهوري اليوم سيخوض المعركه
الانتخابيه ونعرف من سيكون الممثل الرسمي
لهم بعد سنه ونصف تقريبا من اليوم وكثره
تحيين هو شيء جيد لانه سنستمع الى افكار
جديده من كل طرف من كل مرشح بالحزب
الجمهوري واذا كانت الاغلبيه ستصب لمصلحه
الرئيس ترامب لانه جربوه على اربع سنوات
والنتيجه الايجابيه التي اعطوها لمصلحه
اعطاها لمصلحه الشعب الامريكي وليس
لمصلحته الخاصه اما الحزب الديم سيبقى
ينتقد بغض النظر لانه الحزب الديمقراطي
ليس وسطي اصبح يساري متعسس هذا الحزب
الديمقراطي اما رسالته هي ستكون اولا الى
الحزب الجمهوري الذي سيصوت في الانتخابات
التمهيديه
والوسط من بعد الانتخابات التقليديه الوسط
الذين
انه يشكلوا قبه القبان مثل ما نقول لمصلحه
مين ستذهب سده الرئاسه بعد سنه سنتين من
اليوم سننتظر لنرى ذلك وقبلها من هو مرشح
الحزب الجمهوري وكذلك الديمقراطي شكرا
جزيلا يا سيد رئيس التحالف الامريكي الشرق
الاوسطى للديمقراطيه وايضا الشكر موصول
للدكتور ادمنت غريبه الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لكما
الشكر موصول لكم انتم لهذه المتابعه في
امان الكريب
[موسيقى]